ポリジャズ社長ですそうぜひ私も買ってしまいました
僕こういう仕事してるんで職業体すごい頭も使うんですけども結構引く経営者との瀬戸
さんとが買われてると思うんですけども私もついに買ってしまいました
乗っていきますよ
dots 4本だかわかんないんだよたくコレット
お前本当にお前待ってっかーめっちゃくっちゃ願いねってよ入ってるだけですねあの僕
も買ってしまいました
こちら今回方パソコン mac pro ってやってるんですけども
もう色々区妻鹿層だけがこちら705万53104 a
ちょっとずつちょっと待ってくださいパソコンで700万円でどうなっ
700万円の買い物など北マジでしたことないんですよ
手帳紹介させていただくと8僕は今付トリコの mac pro っていう通称ゴミ箱
なんですけどもこちらが出て130万円くらいそれがいつ2個あるんですけどもう
いっちょこれ137いて最高スペックなんですよそれを半々に生まれ
あのな百萬人パソコン一体どんなのなのでしょうか
あの
なんで買ったんでしょなんで簡単でしょても d を発見してるんですよ
2に700ままないやばい迷った左側に買うかたぶん人生で一番高い買い物だったねと
上動画撮っておきましたねードバイのパソコン買うとこんな感じになりますどうぞ
うん
ん
[音楽]
うん
ん
あとった
わー
結構やばい以上でも精神がさすがに回振るのはや無理だよ
いやーなので the sega にダメ
ブーブー
あっこれ
これは
なんだプロディスプレイ xero にたっぽいなこれ私もんだけどなんか70万戸で
1 k する
で5度ウォッチが多いねぇ多いよね多分こっち方面だよね
おっぱっと開けちゃいますね
[音楽]
いません
なにこれこれ本題じゃないかプロスタンドって書いてありますねこれ本題じゃないな
ただのスタンドだなこれ阿部
本来届いてないソロしてきます
[音楽]
奥でるよ怒ってるよあの付属のパーツが届いてから何日待ったことかもほぼ記憶に
ございません
それぐらい待ちましたが大江外いてくださいました700万円のパソコンです
母に待ちましたけれどもまあどんな理由があったとしても僕は
うれしいそれじゃあお願いんですよねやっぱ大学バッグなどこんな ok になっ
ちゃったという
さっそく開けていきましょうめちゃくちゃをも s 4本当にもう園に行ってくれてる
人が多いんですよ
いやマジで今までの人生生きてきてこんなでかいパソコンを止めたことないですはい
授業税の
tan
でガーこれでパソコン用やばいってものサイズがあってか大関で持ち上げられなかった
今までここで同数のやばいなーコレですコレコレをねこっちだから700万のパソコン
ですめっちゃけどもうああっ
邪魔よお前何だスカーフくノ一かピコイ明け方もう行くみたいな路線本体ドンやっぱだ
これがこれがこれを仲間っててお洒落してきて何がマウスですねえっこれもなにこれ
なにこれなにこれなにこれ
ハイパーネックローマン袋黒いんだぜんだけどねは推計あるは黒いですねなんか
イメージが変わっちゃいますってことはこれが間違いなく本体ということか
やばいもんなんか筋トレの器具みたいな落ちてましたねやり masa
落とすわけにはいかのですうわぁああかっこいいヒーロー
組む必要です御家は凄いですクロ武本当はで瀬戸さんとひっかきさんとかと同じくらい
タイムで勝手なんですけどわかんないけど届くのが遅かったりいろいろトラブル方遅く
なっちゃう非常に出遅れた年生がさすがにこんな買い物
動画にする気ねぇだ残すはこれですねこれもそのまま
ストーンしちゃうけどいいオレ大丈夫だよねー
抜けた
ああああああああ
今日して待つ間にこれがケーブルそしてこれが本体ねこれ以上家族にはないでしょうか
多分コレですね表訳さずにつきました700万円バックポロでふわぁ
行くぞ
[音楽]
ブーバー1キッスんっ
大量の大根を一気リスれるような代行王氏のようなフォルム
これが mac pro ですあえてぜひ700万円のパソコ
数えてしまったわけなんですけども専門的なことは何ひとつわかりませんそれで
パソコンが固まらず動画編集できるっていうのを聞いてもう本当にね複雑な編集など
マジでパソコンが止まるんでめっちゃつ時間が無駄になること多い
んですよ tab wi-fi も言ってたと思うんですけども仕事に関するものは
中品のものを使うのが僕は絶対いいかなと思って本会に合わせていただきました
それ以上の高いですそれだけ会社だって言うと体重でこれマジでけっぽかったじゃ普通
に行きますよ
キャスターついてる無理だなこれ横でしていいのかなゆっくり倒しますね
ここで通されたられませ本当に終わりを着ていった
絶対に連れてきましたいますここ
ん4日
バッハというわけでこのるに最強の僕が届いてしまった
観測机に据えてちょっと前にちょっと変なよくわかんないスタンドしてモニター
それぞれセッティングすれば多分完璧な生徒がここにできるところでさっそくやって
いこうと思います
あっえっ
あ
持っています
イゼット ok はウープんっ
[音楽]
あれなんでつかない悪い
さあ考えなねまあねっつかないので電源入ってるわかんな
なぜかつきませんどういうことちょセンパーイ選抜関与ちょヤバイっすよ
えーっいいんじゃないでしょ先輩先輩なんでー
モニターどすなってますよねっ
[音楽]
先輩4パワーウィンドゥ
きませ寄与してくださいようやく動かしたのですがちゃったら170万台版
ようやく動き出しました700万たぞ来たぞ既に動き出しました
7,000,000そう
8海に行っ
ネップにカバー
甘いマークスキャ0
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ